bonjour jean marc jancovici bons joueurs
vous êtes président de de schiste
project & associés de carbone 4 et je
vous reçois aujourd'hui pour aborder la
question est ce que la croissance est
aujourd'hui par le manque
d'énergie vous allez traiter cette
question dans le cadre des geckos les
journées de l'économie dôngs et refit
canal et partenaires alors si l'on peut
lier aussi fortement croissance et
consommation d'énergie comment expliquer
qu'en france la consommation d'énergie
est plutôt reculé alors que le pib a
continué d'augmenter même plus
faiblement c'est tout simplement que
dans le pib on va trouver deux choses on
va trouver ce qui dépend de flux
physiques par exemple la fabrication de
couteaux de table deux chaises de
chemises etc et puis une chose qui n'en
dépend pas qui est l'augmentation de la
valeur des actifs quand vous vendez un
mètre carré deux fois plus cher sans
qu'il y ait deux fois plus de mètres
carrés les flux physiques n'ont pas
changé vous avez pas besoin de plus
d'énergie pour ça et pourtant ça vous a
fait plus de pib ce qui est en train de
se passer depuis 2006 moment où l'europe
est passée par son maximum
d'approvisionnement énergétique depuis
sa baisse c'est tout simplement que les
flux physiques sont tous en train de
baisser on construit moins de logements
la production industrielle baisse et
elle passe pas qu'en france cette baisse
dans tous les pays de l' ocde sauf les
états unis l'allemagne
vous avez les tonnes kilomètres en
camion qui sont en train de baisser vous
avez des passagers kilomètres en train
qui sont en train de baisser enfin en
gros tous les flux physiques sont en
train de baisser depuis qu'on a passé le
maximum énergétique
le pib a également baissé dans un
certain nombre de pays et je vous
rappelle que globalement en europe ça
fait du surplace le pib par habitant a
commencé à baisser mais ils ne baissent
pas aussi vite que l'énergie à cause de
cet artefact en gros dans le calcul du
pib qui est qu'on corrige l'inflation
sur les biens courants et on corrige pas
l'inflation sur les actifs si on corrige
et l'inflation sur les actifs dans le
pib vous constateriez aujourd'hui qu'ils
baissent à peu près à la même vitesse
que la production industrielle alors on
est aujourd'hui en plein débat sur la
stagnation séculaire cette hypothèse
selon laquelle il faudrait s'habituer à
une croissance proche de zéro sur à
moyen et plus long terme alors est ce
que cette croissance zéro cette
hypothèse est liée à une raréfaction des
ressources alors la réponse est oui
quand l'humanité a démarré ce qu'on
appelle la civilisation industrielle
elle a fait quelque chose de très simple
c'est qu'elle a mis les machines au
travail à la place des hommes la veste
que vous portez n'a pas été faite par
des hommes a été faite par des machines
le bureau sur lequel on pose nos mains
enfin le plateau sur lequel on pose nos
mains n'a pas été fait par des hommes il
a été fait par des machines les caméras
qui sont en train de nous filmer n'ont
pas été faites par des hommes elles ont
été faites par les machines et c'est
donc aujourd'hui ce qui produit ces des
machines que mangent les machines pas
des cuisses de poulet mais de l'énergie
donc la quantité d'énergie ou le parc
installé en machines sont aujourd'hui
les deux facteurs dimensionnant de la
production économique d'un pays
industrialisé et si vous avez moins
d'énergie disponible vous aurez moins de
pib si vous avez plus d'énergie
disponible vous aurez plus de pib or
qu'est ce qui se passe pour l'énergie il
se passe que celle que nous utilisons
dans le monde d'aujourd'hui qui est
essentiellement d'origine fossile gaz
pétrole charbon est caractérisée par le
fait qu'on doit trouver des gisements
avant de faire sortir ce qu'ils
contiennent et les premiers gisements
qu'on va trouver ces les plus gros et
les plus mal cachée c'est donc ceux qui
sont le plus facile à exploiter au
moindre coût et qui peuvent vous donner
les débits les plus importants avec le
temps vous allez découvrir des gisements
de plus en plus petit ou très mal
commode à exploiter les gaz de schiste
en soi un exemple y en a beaucoup mais
c'est très belle commode à exploiter et
à ce moment vous allez avoir des débits
qui seront de plus en plus difficile à
faire croître et si on parle un peu
chiffres l'approvisionnement énergétique
dans les pays de l' ocde croissait de 4
à 5% par an pour les années 60 puis
c'est descendu à 3 puis c'est descendu à
2 puis c'est descendu à 1 puis dans les
années 2000 c'est descendu à 0 et
maintenance est en train de décroître au
rythme en gros de l'ordre de 1% par an
en europe on est entre 1 et 2% par an de
décroissance et ce mouvement va
s'amplifier et à cause du fait que c'est
les machines qui produisait pas les
hommes et que les machines manche de
l'énergie le pib va suivre et c'est
exactement ce qu'il a fait sur les 50
dernières années la croissance du pib
était de 5% par an dans la décennie 60
4% par an dans la décennie 70 à zéro en
ce moment et c'est pas une croissance
zéro qui nous attend c'est moins c'est
moins donc malgré malgré tout malgré
tout s'est découvert de nouveaux
gisements l'exploitation d'énergies non
conventionnelles il ya bien une
raréfaction est ce que au moins ça va
permettre de lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique
alors oui mais malgré nous et c'est là
tout le drame de la faire au moment où
on a commencé à comprendre de quoi il
s'agit c'est quand on a parlé du
réchauffement climatique on a essayé
d'inciter les démocraties car il faut
savoir que les démocraties dans le monde
représente 75% des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre le seul gros émetteurs
qui ne soit pas une démocratie c'est la
chine sinon tous les gros émetteurs sont
des démocraties vous rappelez de la
prophétie de tocqueville qui est que les
démocraties serait myope et insouciante
du long terme donc on a essayé de
convaincre les démocraties de bien
vouloir s'occuper du long terme ce
qu'elles n'ont pas fait et à ce moment
comme la planète et philly ce qui finit
par s'occuper du problème à notre place
c'est tout simplement la raréfaction de
l'énergie qui fait que dans un nombre
croissant d'endroits s'est pas encore
toute la planète loin s'en faut il ya
plein de pays qui sont en
approvisionnement croissants en énergie
il ya un nombre croissant de zones où
cet approvisionnement en énergie est en
train de devenir des croissants et à ce
moment vous avez dans un contexte de
récession une baisse des émissions donc
en gros c'est la finitude de la planète
qui se charge de régler le problème à
notre place et à cause de l'inertie du
système climatique qui répond avec des
décennies des siècles des millénaires de
retard à nos émissions c'est notamment
dû à l'inertie de l'océan le fait de
rester les bras croisés ne nous garantit
qu'une chose c'est une dérive climatique
qui va aller grandissant alors même que
nous aurons de moins en moins d'énergie
donc de moins en moins de moyens pour y
faire face donc l'action est urgente
parce que plus le temps passe en ne
prenant pas le taureau par les cornes et
plus nous sommes sûrs d'avoir une double
peine une double peine majeur mais un
jean marc jancovici je ne sais pas si je
dois vous remercier d'avoir dressé ce
tableau assez noir mais merci quand même
d'être venu décrypter ces liens entre
croissance et une consommation d'énergie
sur les africains à merci